Let's check this out. I'm about to show
you this. This is going to blow your
mind. We're going to look at the unholy
trinity of DC and Marvel comics. So,
here we see on the left you see DC. You
see Superman, Batman, and Wonder Woman.
That is officially DC Comics Trinity.
They even have comics called Trinity. On
the right, you see Thor, Iron Man, and
Captain America. That is officially
Marvel's Trinity. They don't have a
comic called Trinity, but you can do
this yourself. You can Google it. You
can look up who is the Marvel universe's
trinity and it will tell you this. Now,
check this out. A lot of people, there
might be some misunderstandings about
the unholy trinity of the book of
Revelation. So, we're going to study
this out a little bit. I can't get into
the whole study. It's huge, but there's
actually a video in uh the playlist on
Candid Truth where you can see who is
the beast and what is his mark. I'll put
a link to that in the description, but
it goes through the whole study. It's
just 30 minutes and it shows you who the
beast is, who the dragon is, who the uh
false prophet is. Now, that's what
that's a symbolic. Remember, Revelation
is written in symbols. There's not
really going to be a harlot riding on a
beast. There's not really going to be
this woman drinking the blood of saints
on a seven-headed dragon, right? There's
not going to be a a woman dressed in
pure white standing on the moon clothed
with the sun. This is all symbolic.
Israel, Babylon. Babylon doesn't exist
today, but yet it's a symbol of the
unrighteous. Israel is a symbol of God's
people, not a not a nation. Remember,
there's neither Jew nor Greek.
Circumcision is nothing. We're all one
in Christ Jesus. Even that might be
controversial to some people, but there
is no Jew and Greek anymore. We are all
one in Christ Jesus. Now, we're going to
get into this. Who are these unholy
trinity? because I've heard some
misunderstandings, but symbolically it's
a dragon. We know there's not really a
dragon, but symbolically there's a
dragon. There is the beast, and we know
according to prophecy that a beast is a
king or a kingdom, and the false
prophet. What does a prophet do? A
prophet points people to worship a
certain individual.
So according to DC comics, you see
Trinity, Trinity, Trinity, you see
Batman, Superman, and Wonder Woman. Now
Marvel, they have the same thing. Thor,
Iron Man, Captain America. You might
already be connecting the dots. You
might already be if you know Bible
prophecy, you know the symbols of Bible
prophecy and who the dragon, who the
beast, and who the false prophet prophet
represent, you may already be connecting
the dots because now that I see it, I
can't unsee it.
And I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs come out of the mouth of the
dragon and out of the mouth of the beast
and out of the mouth of the false
prophet. So we know that the dragon, the
beast, and the false prophet, this is
the unholy trinity. What do these
symbols represent? The dragon, the
beast, and the false prophet. The
dragon, the beast, the false prophet,
and the great dragon was cast out, that
old serpent called the devil and Satan,
which deceiveth the whole world.
So we know that the dragon is Satan.
It's not a dragon. It's the fallen angel
Lucifer is Satan because that Bible
verse just told us. Now, who is the
beast? According to Bible prophecy, if
you study this out, this might be
controversial. You need to study this
out. The beast is the Vatican. It's the
Roman papacy. And we know that according
to the statue of Nebuchadnezzar and the
four beasts that rise out of the the sea
and in the book of Daniel and also the
woman that's riding the seven-headed
dragon in the book of Revelation, all
these are parallels to each other. And
the false prophet is America. That might
sound super controversial to you. You
might not understand that at all, but
I'm telling you guys, study this out.
We're going to go through it a little
bit. I can't go through the whole thing,
but just trust me, when you study this
out, you will see it clearly. It cannot
be any other nation. No kingdom fits the
false prophet except America 100% hands
down. Uh Nebuchadnezzar in the book of
Daniel had a dream about an image and
that image represented different metals.
The head was gold which represented
Babylon. The chest and arms were of
silver and that represented the Mes and
the Persians coming together to unite
and take over Babylon. Then the belly
and thighs of brass was Greece which
conquered Meo Persia. Then the iron legs
were Rome. That fulfilled that prophecy
has been fulfilled. And we see that
Bible prophecy is 100% true and accurate
and you you can't refuse it. This stuff
was written back in the in the Old
Testament. Daniel wrote this. And the
feet, the last kingdom, the feet are of
miry clay and still iron. Iron
represents who? Rome. Now the feet are
mixed with miry clay, which is dirty
clay. Let me let me tell you this. Clay,
we he is the potter. We are the clay,
right? The church is the body of Christ.
We are the clay. But what do you think
about miry clay? That's dirty clay.
That's a corrupt church, a corrupt group
of people mixed with iron, which is
Rome. So now you're talking about the
last kingdom after this long reign of
Rome. Now you have a final kingdom
that's a it's a dirty corrupt church
that's Roman. Think about that. Who is
that? What's the only church government
church state system in Rome is the
Vatican, the papacy, the papal empire.
And in the last days, that system is
going to rise again. It suffered a fatal
wound, but then it came back. And and
these are a parallel. These kingdoms are
a parallel to those four beasts in
another part of Daniel where it says the
lion with wings, that is Babylon. The
bear raised on one side, that's me,
Persia. The the leopard with four heads
and wings, that was Greece. The beast
with iron teeth, remember iron
represents Rome. Now you got this beast
with iron teeth. That's still Rome. And
then Rome and then it goes back. It's
it's called repeat and enlarge. You're
talking about in Bible prophecy, you're
going to repeat it. You're going to zoom
in. You're going to show more detail.
And in the book of Revelation, you have
this woman which represents a church,
but now it's a harlot. That's that
corrupt church. And she's riding on a
beast with seven heads. And the Bible
says that the seven heads are seven
hills or mountains. And what is the city
of seven hills? Google it. What is the
city of seven hills? Rome. So you got
this woman, this corrupt harlot sitting
on a city of seven hills, which is Rome.
And it's this church state union. You
guys need to study this stuff out. So
we're going to look at this these
parallels. The dragon, the beast, and
the false prophet. And we got Marvel's
trinity, and we got DC's trinity. How do
they relate to the dragon, the beast,
and the false prophet? We'll take a look
at Thor and Batman first because they
are actually parallels to each other.
What do they have in common? Let's check
it out. What is What Who would Thor be?
Would he be the dragon, the beast, or
the false prophet? Let's check this clip
out.
You are a vain, greedy, cruel boy.
I
know. This is, isn't it?
So, who does Thor represent? his father
up there in this beautiful kingdom just
cast him out like a bolt of lightning
and then Thor said what? Oh no, this is
earth, isn't it? Who was cast out of
heaven to as lightning to earth? Satan.
So Thor is Satan, which is the dragon
according to this uh these symbols in
Bible prophecy. Now we're going to take
a listen to who Batman is. You know,
Superman is Zeus. Batman is Hades.
Aquaman is Neptune.
So he just said that Batman is Hades.
Who is Hades? The god of the underworld.
Who does that sound like? Here's another
one.
His iconography is that of a dead demon.
I mean, look at the paintings of
medieval paintings of devils in museums.
The bat wings, the horns. So he just
told you that Batman is not based off of
a bat. He's based off of a demon. He's
like, "Look at the gargoyle, the horns,
the bat wings. These are straight from
the artist's mouth. This isn't me trying
to twist something. I'm not just some
religious zealot making stuff up. This
is straight from the horse's mouth. So,
Batman is the demon. They even have
comics called Birth of the Demon, Son of
the Demon, Tales of the Demon. Batman is
Satan. Thor is Satan. So, together they
are both the dragon which represents
Satan. We always hear people say, "So,
what do you think? just a bunch of
directors or in some smoke filled room
saying, "Oh, how can we deceive the
Christians?" No, we don't believe that.
We believe that inspiration comes from
somewhere. If you're walking with God
and you're asking God, Lord, um, not my
words, but your words, Lord, give me the
words to say, speak through me. Then
you're going to be filled with the Holy
Spirit. You're asking God to guide and
direct your words. But if you are like
these people and you're dabbling in the
occult, you're messing around with drugs
and alcohol, you're having dreams and
visions, these these directors say, "I
got I got Avatar from a dream. Yeah, I I
got Harry Potter from a dream." These
people are getting their inspiration
from somewhere. You are inspirited,
inspired from one side or the other. And
that's what we think's going on. And
it's on a worldwide scale. I mean, it
even happens in tons of anime, which in
Japan, there's less than 1% of
Christianity. And yet they still have
the inverted gospel message. So Iron Man
and Wonder Woman, what in the world do
they have in common? They don't even
seem like they connect in any kind of
way. But we're about to find out. Iron
Man, who does he represent? Is he He's
not the dragon. We already got the
dragon knocked out. Is he the beast or
the false prophet?
Remember in that dream? Remember in the
dream that Nebuchadnezzar had iron man?
who was iron and the legs of iron that
represented Rome. So basically you you
replace the word iron with Rome and you
have Rome man. You have the remember the
iron teeth represented Rome. You have
the Rome man. And the Rome man is the
the head of the Catholic Church, the
head of the Vatican, which is the pope.
And I'm not saying any specific pope.
Any pope, any pope that sits on that
throne wears that miter on his head that
says, "I am the vicer of Christ. I am
vicarious file day. I'm the replacement
of the son of God. Call no man father
but your father in heaven."
If you haven't heard this stuff, Jesus
said, "Call no man father but your
father in heaven." Um they they accused
Jesus of blasphemy because he he um
forgave sins and he proclaimed to be
God. And so this man in Rome in the
church he proclaims to be God. They call
him the holy father. He proclaims to be
able to have the power to forgive sins.
He is committing blasphemy. The
revelation says that that though this is
the one who speaks blasphemies has the
name of blasphemy on their head. This is
the antichrist. The pope. I'm not saying
Pope Francis. I'm not saying any of the
previous popes. I'm saying every man
that sits in that position becomes the
man of sin. And it says in Revelation
13:18, it says, "Here is wisdom. Let him
who has understanding calculate the
number of the beast, for it is the
number of a man. His number is 666." So
the man who is a part of this beast of
Rome, he is the antichrist. He's the
666. And so Iron Man is the antichrist.
And it even says it in Men's Health
magazine. And they said, "Marvel Comics
just casually revealed that Iron Man is
the Antichrist. This is not a Christian
organization that's putting these dots
together." It says, "Over in the comics,
meanwhile, the absolute opposite is
happening. Stark, Tony Stark, has just
learned that he is the literal
antichrist." This is not me speaking.
It's It's not even a religious person.
This is Men's Health magazine said that
Iron Man just casually revealed that
he's the antichrist. Now we're seeing
that he's the iron man, the Rome man.
So, how does this connect with Wonder
Woman? Wonder Woman, how does she
connect? First thing on, first off,
she's dressed like a harlot and she's
wearing scarlet. Isn't that interesting?
Just like the scarlet that's on the
sevenheaded beast, who also represents
this false system of worship, this Roman
papacy system.
And when you read Revelation 7 17:7, it
says, "And the angel said to me,"Wh do
you wonder?" Ah, why do you wonder? I
will tell you the mystery of the woman
and of the beast that carries her, which
has the seven heads and the 10 horns.
Look at this. John in the book of
Revelation is wondering after a woman.
And now you call a comic hero wonder
woman. And she's part of the Marvel
trinity or the DC trinity. The DC
trinity. Isn't it crazy? Wonder Woman.
And John wondered after this woman, this
mysterious woman.
This is not a stretch. This is every
piece is fitting together. So you got
Rome, you got the Iron Man and the
Scarlet Woman who represent the beast
which is Rome. Now, we're going to look
at how can Captain America and Superman
fit the identity of the false prophet.
If you understand Bible prophecy and
that the false prophet is America,
because when you read Revelation, it
says that a false prophet will cause the
world to worship the beast. That's why
it's a prophet because this nation is
saying, "Worship this nation, worship
this religious system." That's a that's
what a prophet does. They remember John
the Baptist said, "Behold the lamb of
God." He was a prophet pointing people
to Jesus. Now you have this lamblike
beast that has risen out of the earth.
You got to you got to do this study
yourself. Waters represent many peoples.
That's why Rome uh the beast came out of
the waters. But this new beast that came
out after Rome, there's only one nation
that did this is America. It rose out of
the earth, a desolate place. And it had
two horns like a lamb, a lamblike
nation, a Christian nation, supposed
Christian nation, but it speaks as a
dragon. It speaks like Satan does.
That's America. It can only be America.
There's so many more evidences, but
that's all I can give you right now. So,
if if the false prophet is America, who
do we have here, but Captain
America?
Captain America. It's right there in his
name. He's got the red, white, and blue.
has got the star and then Superman.
Who's more American than Superman? He is
the truth, the justice, and the American
way as he salutes with the American
flag. When you think of America, you
think of Coca-Cola, Mickey Mouse,
Superman, McDonald's. These are all
icons of American pop culture. Superman
is the absolute epitome of America, the
false prophet. There was even a book
called The American Way and it says the
true story of Nazi escape, Superman and
Marilyn Monroe. This is just showing
that icons of America like the Statue of
Liberty and Marilyn Monroe and Superman
are all icons of America. Here we have
it. Let's recap. Thor and Batman are
Satan the dragon.
Iron Man and the Wonder Woman, the woman
that John wondered after represents
Rome, the beast of Revelation. And we
have Captain America and Superman who
represent America, the false prophet.
This is insane. There's no way this is a
coincidence. You cannot make this stuff
up. This is just absurd. There's no way
this is made up. This is seriously
inspired by Satan himself. That's how so
many movies, so many books, so many
video games have this Gnostic gospel. I
don't even think the writers understand
what they're doing. I truly don't. I
think that they just wake up and they
say, "You know what? It'd be really cool
if uh the bad guy was this all powerful
villain in space and he's sitting on a
throne in a spaceship called the
sanctuary and he wants to come to Earth
and destroy half of humanity separating
the sheep from the goats." This is exact
I'm describing Thanos, but I'm
describing Jesus at the same time. I
don't think that these directors and
stuff even know what's happening, but
they're being inspired. And this is too
coincidental. There's no way that this
is a coincidence. If you were blessed by
this video,
if you were blessed by this video, share
this with somebody. Please give it a
thumbs up. It's a simple and easy and
free way to support this ministry. It
helps to get this video out into the
algorithm. If you would like to buy a
t-shirt, we have t-shirts on our shop.
Go to candidtruth.org.
We got Cash App with Candid Truth
Official. We got Vinmo, Mikey Jenny,
that's my name. We got Zel with
executebrand@gmail.com.
That is my email address. We also have
these t-shirts on our website. If you go
to candidtruth.org, we got uh the
t-shirt of our logo. We got this cool
t-shirt. We're coming out new shirts all
the time. You can get mugs, iPhone
cases, whatever you want. But what this
logo represents, what our official logo
represents is that it's cool to use your
brain. With so much propaganda in the
world is Beas and Buttad. Oh, you want
to be cool? You want to sit on the couch
all day and get high? Or uh even back as
like Family Matters, you had Eddie who
was, you know, really dumb and, you
know, went to parties and stuff, but he
always got the girls and he was always
cool, right? And who was the one that
was uncool? The really smart Urkl who
was getting shoved in the locker, right?
What about Save by the Bell? Screech,
the smart guy, was always getting shoved
in the lockers. But the cool guy, Zack
Morris, who never did his homework,
always got the girl, was always dumb.
Right. This propaganda has been in our
faces all the time to be dumb because
dumb is cool. And it's this system to to
make you shut your brain off so that
you're more easily controlled. But we're
going to break that system. And we're
saying it is actually cool to use your
brain. And it's cool to think about
things and analyze things and to know
the truth because the truth will set you
free. And the truth is in the word of
God. And he's given us eyes to see and
ears to hear. And we want to spread that
truth to you. And we want to wake up the
sleeping giant. It's time to wake up.
We've been asleep for too long. I
believe Jesus is coming soon. If you
like this video, give it a thumbs up.
Share it with all your family and
friends. If you're new, subscribe. And
we'll see you next time.